[Musique]
avec moi pour évoquer le futur des
guerres sans fin de l'otan et la fin de
la plus longue guerre de l'histoire des
états unis le légendaire john pilger
john merci infiniment d'être avec nous
cette semaine c'est le plus grand salon
de l'armement ici à londres on sait
qu'ils ont bombardé la syrie les
israéliens eux armés par les
britanniques l'union européenne et les
etats unis ont bombardé gaza mais
penchons nous d'abord sur l'afghanistan
alors que ce sont les 20 ans des
attentats du 11 septembre est ce que les
américains et les britanniques sont
partis comme ils sont venus clan parfois
des enfants nous avons vu des frappes de
drones nous avons vu le chaos à
l'aéroport de kaboul sans parler des
conditions dans lesquelles sont morts ce
de très nombreuses personnes des soldats
américains étant impliqué parfois dans
la mort de civils quel est votre regard
là-dessus pour les cvthèques wor
sécurité et bien cette machine à tuer
afshin cette machine à tuer au vietnam
ils appelaient l'armée américaine la
machine verte à cause de sa couleur
puis ils ont changé quand je dit il je
veux dire ceux qui comprennent vraiment
la propagande
comment la propagande nous a menti au
fil des années
c'est vraiment une machine à tuer
vous parlez de ce salon de l'armement
quand c'était accessible
l'un des missiles était le mk 82 c'est
une bombe de précision de 500 livres
ça n'est pas exactement un missile mais
s'étaient lancés par des f 16
j'ai vu en afghanistan ce que l'une de
ces choses à faire à un village et à une
famille
le nom de la femme dont la famille a été
liquidée et aide au raf
elle avait une famille de je crois
sept membres
son mari et six enfants qui ont été tués
lorsque l'une de ces mk82
c'était très certainement l'une de
celles présentes à ce salon de
l'armement
qui était présenté avec tant de fierté
et à cette époque
peut-être pas des gens comme moi
mais d'autres journalistes et qui
n'était pas ce qu'on appelle des
correspondants de défense
pouvait y entrer et voir ce qu on y
vendait
on n'a pas pu y avoir accès non bien sûr
que non alors je dois dire que cette
émission est diffusée en afghanistan
comme partout dans le monde et certains
afghans 70 % étant des ruraux et je ne
parle pas de kaboul vont se demander est
ce que cette guerre qui est considéré
comme une bonne guerre par les libéraux
par ce tram heures et johnson ici par
les démocrates américains par pelosi et
c est ce que les britanniques et les
américains sont incompétents
très certainement incompétent
mais la plupart des impérialistes sont
incompétents ils font des erreurs et eu
beaucoup de gens qui n'avaient pas
l'intention de tuer du moins c'est ce
qu'ils disent
pendant vingt ans cette guerre est allé
vers une issue certaine
nous avons des pouvoirs impérialistes
qui se sont retirés on en a eu assez de
l'afghanistan on a dépensé vous le savez
sans doute quelque chose comme mais il
milliards de dollars mais ça ne va nulle
part
bon de toute façon nous avons un autre
ennemi à l'horizon les britanniques
viennent d'envoyer un nouveau porte
avions pour faire peur à ce nouvel
ennemi la chine donc il a le souhait
d'aller ailleurs
les stratèges du ministère de la défense
et du pentagone à washington
sont en train d'écrire un nouveau
scénario
il s'agira encore de tuer des gens
si vous regardez comme je les ai vus les
jeux de guerre pour la chine le nombre
de tués qu'ils prédisent dans une
réaction à ce qu'ils appellent une
attaque chinoise ou dans leurs propres
attaques préventif se chiffrent en
millions
donc les vies civiles et qu'il s'agisse
d'une famille comme celle dont j'ai vu
la tragédie l'atrocité en afghanistan où
deux millions
c'est toujours l'impérialisme
il faut utiliser ce terme sam est très
important et non ce n'est pas un terme
d'un guide propaganda des années 60 il
fut un temps où c'était un département
soviétique qui disposait d'une grande
respectabilité
en fait dans ce pays des gens se sont
battus pour défendre leur réputation d'
impérialistes
des chrétiens sortant de lempire pour
diffuser non seulement un message mais
aussi le pouvoir du centre de l' empire
et c'est ce qu'on a eu pendant vingt ans
en afghanistan
j'ai couvert l'afghanistan j'ai couvert
le vietnam presque toutes les guerres
impliquant mon propre pays le royaume
uni l'australie les etats-unis
ça a été une guerre impérialiste
c'est à dire que nous ce mot qui est
utilisé avec une telle responsabilité
par les médias
nous envahissons le pays de quelqu'un
d'autre
et bien sûr il y a une raison à cela
si vous prenez la raison pour laquelle
j'ai regardé sky news hier soir et je
suis sûr qu'ils ne sont pas pires que
d'autres
il expliquait que le 11-septembre
retrouver ses origines
sa préparation et son exécution en
afghanistan
ce n'est pas du tout vrai
vous savez l'afghanistan a été un bouc
émissaire si vous voulez
la préparation a été effectuée aux états
unis et il n'y avait pas un seul afghan
parmi eux ils étaient majoritairement
saoudien
tout cela a été effacé de notre
conscience de notre conscience au
quotidien
la réticence volontaire la réticence
délibéré
a expliqué pourquoi
nous allons en réalité dans des pays
là où nous sommes à l'heure actuelle et
les etats unis le royaume uni les pays
occidentaux pourquoi nous faisons cela
ce que nous espérons en tirer
c'est un projet du 20e siècle
on ne porte plus de casques coloniaux
mais on pourrait bien c'est là qu'il ya
cette réticence à appréhender et
comprendre l'histoire récente
comme je le disais l'impérialisme n'est
pas un terme daguise propaganda
il a pris une connotation péjorative
pendant la seconde guerre mondiale
parce que hitler était aussi
impérialiste mais c'est ce qu'a été
l'afghanistan c'est ce qui a été le
vietnam c'est ce qui a été et l'irak
quand vous avez quelqu'un que je
qualifierais quasiment de caricatures d'
impérialistes comme tony blair
ce qui tient de tels propos
d'où cet homme tire t'il son arrogance
dire que le pouvoir qui pèse sur nous de
nos jours
comme il y a 20 ans
sont tous ces affreuses islamistes que
ça n'a rien à voir avec nous
et quand vous regardez ce que blair
disait à l'époque
à l'époque de l'invasion de
l'afghanistan
c'est un moment qu'il faut saisir
disait-il après le 11 septembre le
kaléidoscope a été agité
les morceaux tournent
bientôt ils se remettront en place
avant cela il faut réordonner le monde
autour de nous pour moi ce sont là les
propos les plus claires d'un
impérialistes
en d'autres termes on va aller dans un
pays on va le détruire on va tout
changer on va miner sa culture on va
tuer ces gens et en faire un meilleur
endroit
quand je dis cela à l'ancien chef d'état
major de la défense ici au ministère de
la défense j'ai eu la rare occasion de
mener une interview il ya quelques
années avec soeur david richard's le
général david richards
je lui ai dit cela je lui ai cité une
célèbre afghane malalai joya
c'est ce qu'elle a dit concernant les
véritables raisons expliquant la
présence de l'occident dans son pays
et ça n'avait rien à voir avec de
l'altruisme il a perdu ses nerfs
et m'a dit que j'étais un apologiste des
talibans mais je dois reconnaître qu'il
s'était ensuite excusé c'était un des
généraux moderne en relations publiques
même lui vous avez touché quelque chose
de sensible là j'ai touché quelque chose
de sensible c'est ça alors j'invite les
gens à regarder
le coming in china pour ce qui est de
l'avenir de wade n 6 sur votre site john
pilger point com mais il faut dire que
l'afghanistan est considéré par les
libéraux comme une bonne guerre
comme je le disais plus tôt et on répète
souvent que les racines de tout cela se
trouve dans l'affrontement avec les
russes qu'ils étaient venus en soutien à
najib ou là et qui a fait tant de choses
pour l'éducation des femmes et c'est ce
qui fait que le mi6 et la cia ont aidé
les moudjahidine qui allait se
transformer en talibans en al-qaïda en
des ch
c'était un projet qui s'appelait
l'opération cyclone
s'était destinée à détruire tout
gouvernement progressiste qui
apparaîtrait à kaboul
et un gouvernement est effectivement
apparu en 1978 le gouvernement du pdp a
c'était un gouvernement des plus
progressistes
égalité des droits pour les femmes à
l'alphabétisation qui était alors de 30%
en afghanistan est passé à 90 % en
l'espace de dix ans
encore une fois quand je faisais
référence plutôt à cette réticence à
apprendre quelque chose de l'histoire
pour répondre à votre question sur la
bonne guerre
à l'époque de ce gouvernement
les etats unis c'est un câble de
l'ambassade des etats-unis à kaboul en
1979 qui a fuité
l'ambassade américaine rapporte que la
disparition du gouvernent man du pdp a
va dans le sens des intérêts supérieurs
des états unis en dépit des revers que
cela peut impliquer pour les futures
réformes économiques et sociales en
afghanistan
en d'autres termes les droits des femmes
n'ont aucune importance
les droits des pauvres n'ont aucune
importance le mi6 la cia oui nous
voulons ce pays nous le voulons pour
différentes raisons
c'est un endroit très important sur le
plan stratégique
les talibans loin d'être là où le 11
septembre a été pensé et organisé
constituait un état client des états
unis
peu de gens savent cela sous
l'administration clinton
les leaders talibans dont certains que
nous voyons aujourd'hui ont été invités
aux états unis
ils sont allés très secrètement à disney
world
ont fait du shopping dans les magasins
target
et ils sont allés voir la cia à langley
pourquoi parce que les états unis
voulaient qu'une compagnie pétrolière
américaine
construisent un pipeline gazier
du turkménistan au pakistan a à travers
l'afghanistan
c'était crucial
les routes alternatives étaient à
travers la russie et l'iran ce qui
n'allait pas
ce n'est que lorsque georges beaulieu
bush est arrivé au pouvoir que son
administration a commencé à se poser des
questions sur la fiabilité des talibans
dans la réalisation de ce projet est à
la tête de ce projet se trouvait dick
cheney
qui est devenu le vice-président de bush
john pilger je dois vous arrêter là a
tout de suite après la pause
[Musique]
de retour avec le légendaire réalisateur
et journaliste john pilger à qui on doit
des films comme droit dedans si
on faisait référence au coût de la
guerre dans son ensemble au delà de ses
origines
à moins que ce soit dans dow et si
julian assange dit que l'un des aspects
de tout cela relève du blanchiment
d'argent que peu importe que ce soit
1000 milliards ou humides milliards que
c'est une manière de prendre l'argent du
contribuable l'argent des travailleurs
des pays occidentaux pour alimenter cinq
gros groupes de défense le complexe
militaro-industriel défense
et ça représente beaucoup d'argent
mais c'est une manière de financer des
projets impérialistes
je veux dire à la fin des années 90 les
talibans étaient tellement proches de
l'administration américaine
qu'il a été calculé
que chaque responsable taliban étaient
payés avec les impôts des américains
ils n'étaient pas payées directement
bien sûr
quand julian assange parlait de
blanchiment d'argent de sommes
gigantesques à travers l'afghanistan
cela s'est mal passé
cela s'est mal passé pour eux à kaffrine
n'ont pas eu ce qu'il voulait tout comme
les choses se sont mal passées en irak
tout comme les choses se sont mal
passées au vietnam c'est souvent ainsi
que ça se passe
est ce qu'il y a une dimension de classe
à prendre en compte concernant les
afghans qui sont interviewés sur nos
écrans
ce sont de toute évidence des citadins
il parle qu'anglais or comme je les dis
l'afghanistan et rurales à 70% quand ils
répondent à des questions pour la
télévision britannique
ou la télé américaine la télé française
il estime touche comme l'interviewer
qu'essentiellement le camp des pays de
l'otan fait preuve d'altruisme et ça
sonne un peu faux ces afghans
interviewés ne semble pas dire qu'il y a
quelque chose de néfaste dans ses
intentions et internes chase
non parce que les afghans qui sont
interviewés en ont en majorité
bénéficier ces gens à l'aéroport en
était des bénéficiaires dans d'autres
guerres ils pourraient être considérées
comme des collaborateurs
c'est ce qu'ils ont été en un sens
mais ils ont clairement été bénéficiaire
et il ne fait aucun doute que des écoles
pour femmes et des écoles pour filles
ont été mises en place à kaboul et elle
était progressiste mais ce qu'on ne nous
a jamais dit c'est que quand vous allez
dans l'arrière-pays l'incroyable
arrière-pays d'afghanistan le pays le
plus sauvage du monde selon moi d'une
très grande beauté c'est la féodalité
une féodalité où ces moudjahidine
ces seigneurs de la guerre gèrent leur
petit fief
et ils font commerce de femmes
de jeunes garçons
qui contrôle le trafic d'héroïne
et la cia qui était leur principal
soutien suivi de près par le mi6 savait
tout cela
donc quand vous parlez de classe
comparer ces gens assez sauvage si vous
voulez des féodaux du moyen-âge
ces gens dont les états unis ont miné le
gouvernement du pdp a
comparé les à ceux qui sont interviewés
à la télévision ces dernières semaines
j'ai vu une interview où on devait être
amené à ressentir de la compassion
pour un ancien procureur en chef à
kaboul
quelqu'un de très éduquée qui a
probablement un diplôme aux états unis
ou au royaume uni
kaboul était une enclave dans un pays
féodal en
grève
est donc fort
le renversement de cette classe
c'était le but de ce gouvernement qui a
disparu
le gouvernement du bdp à en 1978 miné
par les états unis et ensuite détruits
dans les moudjahidine va il devait
changer cette dimension de classe en
afghanistan
et plus spécifiquement il faut
mentionner ashraf ghani qui était
qualifié par la bbc d'incorruptible il y
à peine quelques mois il a passé le plus
clair de son temps aux états unis arrive
à la banque mondiale ensuite on l'envoie
en russie pour la banque mondiale il ya
des millions de morts à cause de la
baisse de l'espérance de vie due aux
réformes néolibérales après la chute de
l'union soviétique
et puis il finit en afghanistan à
l'issue d'une élection frauduleuse
encore un membre de la classe
néolibérale qui peut être parachuté
est-ce que l'on peut encore s'attendre à
ce genre de choses alors que l' empire
faiblit que l' empire américain faibli
vous avez raison mais je ne sais pas si
je dirais à
parachuter il n'a pas gagné l'élection
et il est maintenant en fuite avec de
l'argent ce qu'il nie
le terme poli dans disons les pays
médiévaux les pays vraiment sous
développés et celui de classe marchande
ce qui est bien trop polis à
en afghanistan cette classe savait où
était l'argent
et a produit une classe qui a vraiment
pris le pouvoir
et en parallèle le pays est resté
medieval
on en vient au 20e anniversaire du
11-septembre et bien sûr le 11 septembre
dont on parlera sur aucune chaîne de
télévision c'est celui du chili en 1973
que vous mentionner d'endroit 86 et cela
concerne cette classe mercantile les
origines en quelque sorte de l'école de
chicago quel est votre sentiment
là-dessus même s'il faut avoir en tête
que c'est le 20e anniversaire des
attaques de new york bien sûr
eh bien on n'en parle pas pour les mêmes
raisons qu'on ne parle pas du grand
salon de l'armement qui est de l'autre
côté de la rue et
les gens n'ont aucune idée on n'en parle
pas
et ce n'est parce que ce n'est pas
convenable d'en parler parce qu'il ya un
élément de vérité inconvenant
le 11 septembre 1973 pour les chiliens
que ça concerne ceux qui ont perdu tant
de membres de leurs familles
aux mains de la terrible sauvagerie de
pinochet
et de ses soutiens américains
voilà ce qu'est le 11 septembre
on n'en parle jamais de par le monde
parce que
je ne pense pas que le terme de
un
lavage de cerveau
soit une exagération
nous sommes noyés dans un tsunami de
propagande
le centre du monde le centre
d'importance
c'est les etats-unis
le jour où le monde a changé
je ne pense pas que ce soit le jour où
le monde a changé en fait je pense que
le monde a changé bien avant la guerre
de corée
quand les etats-unis ont décidé
qu'ils allaient devenir une vraie
puissance impérialiste
il a aussi certainement changé avec la
chute du mur de berlin
nous sommes conditionnés pour croire que
tout ce qui tourne autour de cet
événement particulier et seulement cela
mérite un devoir de mémoire
non et pas les gens au chili
seuls les etats-unis méritent le deuil
afghane au phare pas au raf à la femme
avec ses six enfants morts en
afghanistan nous sommes tellement
arriérés nous avons encore atteindre
cette égalité de conscience concernant
les êtres humains
ce qui arrive aux états unis voilà ce
qui importe tout le reste provient de ça
pour finir sur julian assange on
s'appelle que pinochet il était ici en
résidence surveillée dans une luxueuse
maison avec madame thatcher qui lui
rendait visite une possible extradition
d'assange revient à l'envoyer dans une
prison de haute sécurité oui oui
julian et
j'étais au tribunal 11 août
pour écouter un juge en chef
je suis plus surpris qu'ils arrivent
comme ça et tente de discréditer un
témoin d'une manière que je trouvais
révoltante
mais les 27 et 28
il y aura une audience pour savoir
si les états unis ont gagné en appel
contre l'interdiction de l'extradition
de julian vers les états unis
je pense que c'est probablement
d'un point de vue légal la journée
la plus importante peut-être pas de ma
vie
mais du moins de l'époque contemporaine
à cause de ce que ça dira de la liberté
d'expression
de ce que ça dira du journalisme de ce
que ça dira de notre humanité
c'est quelqu'un qui n'a pas commis de
crime
c'est quelqu'un d'agréable
d'intellectuels qui a fait ce que les
vrais journalistes font
et ils se voient puni pour cela
peut-être reste-t-il encore quelque
chose de la justice britannique
tu tes cheveux pour que ce jour là les
juges décident
à comme ils le doivent qu'il devrait
être libéré je ne sais pas john pilger
merci
[Musique]